sheriff joe lombardo and detectives
telling us how they zeroed in on their
suspect eight news now investigator
david charns live outside the clark
county detention center where gearman's
accused murderer is awaiting that next
court appearance david what are you
learning
yeah christian as you heard in vanessa's
reporting there 45 year old robert ellis
is due in court next week right now he
is being held at the clark county
detention center behind me there as the
80s now investigators first told you
this afternoon dna that was found under
jeff gearman's fingernails led to tell
us as a suspect that sample taken early
wednesday morning
every murder is tragic
but the killing of a journalist is
particularly troublesome
clark county sheriff joe lombardo and
las vegas metro police investigators say
45-year-old robert tellis quickly became
a suspect in 69-year-old jeff german's
murder we knew that as an investigative
reporter he had written several articles
and there were different allegations and
statements about potential people that
would be upset about it gearman had
published several articles about
harassment and a possible affair in the
public administrator's office detectives
now say this video is telus walking to
german's home on friday september 2nd
sources say telus is accused of stabbing
german seven times in his neck and torso
video then showed this car later
determined to be registered in telus's
wife's name parking in front of
gearman's home after the murder we
ultimately developed video evidence that
showed that that vehicle the gmc denali
parked in front of telus's home had
departed around 9 00 a.m in the morning
on the day of the murder and returned
around 12 p.m just after the murder
which matched our timeline it wasn't
until a day later saturday that a
neighbor found german's body in a side
yard he was consensually interviewed
voluntarily interviewed
he had the opportunity to obtain a
attorney
he chose not to and subsequent
termination of the interview he was let
go at that time did you do this did you
commit this murder later in the
afternoon telus returned home that
prompted a two-hour standoff with swat
called in sources saying inside telus
harmed himself and may have attempted to
take narcotics so is there going to be
any look at not releasing a potential
murder suspect back to his home like
that we have a very
professional and effective way of how we
safely take people into custody in these
types of very dynamic situations and
that was proven yesterday something
could have happened in that two-hour
window we wanted to provide a medical
attention which we were successful in
doing so and then we also wanted to make
sure that we were consulting with our
district attorney's office and ensuring
a solid uh case to keep building
evidence and that's what we did
successfully thank you
the captain also saying this morning
that it appeared that german was working
on more stories about telus of course
who lost his democratic primary race in
june for what he says according to what
police say was because of german's
reporting so it appears that german's
own stories may have actually led police
to their suspect we're live in downtown
las vegas this afternoon i'm david
charns 8 news now